hello this video starts out with a
review of the drama around the public
demo of the Galactica model and then
goes into a paper review if you're not
in the mood for any drama skip ahead
about 16 minutes and you'll be fine
hello there Galactica is a Model A
language model by meta AI that is
trained specifically on scientific text
now this is a generative model so it can
generate stuff and thereby and can do a
lot of things for example as you can see
right here citation prediction you give
something in and you ask it to predict a
citation and the citation in this case
is correct this is not trained to
predict citations that just happens by
means of it being trained on scientific
text there is also for example this here
translate the math formula into plain
English and there is plain English over
here now the model can do so much more
the point of the paper is actually to
say that look these models we don't have
to train them on these huge corpora of
text we can reduce the Corpus size but
if the Corpus is well curated
qualitatively higher then there might
also be a benefit in that it might be a
trade off between giant corpora and
small corpora that are of higher quality
now the other thing about this paper is
that the model is released fully open
source and they even had a demo up but
as you can see right now it just says
thanks everyone for trying the demo now
I've tried the demo about for a bunch of
things it was really funny you can make
some fun stuff you can also make some
serious stuff in fact Galactica was used
to write the paper that we're going to
read in just a second but the demo was
taken down and despite here it seemingly
being like you know this is just a fun
thing that we wanted to take down anyway
probably probably not yunder car on
Twitter gives a little bit of a hint of
what happened right here pretty much
exactly what happened well what is this
people started complaining as they do
Gary Marcus here says the rapid removal
of meta ai's Galactica demo represent a
tacit acknowledgment that it was
released too soon and deeply problematic
of course problematic the the word that
you can throw at anything and contrast
strikingly with yanlokan's untenable
Public Defense of the project yesterday
someone answered
or maybe it was removed because people
like you abused the model and
misrepresented it thanks for getting
useful and interesting public demo
removed this is why we can't have nice
things to that the other car answers
pretty much exactly what happened met up
huge props to getting this model out
there the model is still available also
getting the demo out there for people to
just try it and yes people tried it as
it was intended and people tried it as
it wasn't intended a lot of funny stuff
was done and also someone might have
entered a bad word oh no oh no but
people pretty quickly started obviously
to complain the professional complainers
and the people who think they know
what's good for you obviously were all
over this so Michael Black says I asked
Galactic about some things I know about
and I'm troubled in all cases it was
wrong or biased but sounded right and
authoritative I think that's dangerous
dangerous dangerous right
here are a few of my experiments in yada
yada yada so here it tries to justify
why dangerous Galactic Galactica
generates text that's grammatical and
feels real this text Will slip into real
scientific submissions it will be
realistic but wrong or biased it would
be hard to detect it will influence how
people think you you catch the like the
step like
it produces text that feels real this
text Will slip into real scientific
submissions like how it just will it's
just like no no one has a part in it
just like the model exists therefore
text and scientific submissions by the
way humans can also do like bad stuff
humans can also lie and plagiarize and
write grammatically real but wrong
things in fact the literature is
littered with wrong math proofs not even
intentionally wrong just like they look
right they're essentially two or three
kinds of people they're the people who
think we know what's good for you and
therefore we must be the Guardians of
all the models then there are the people
who just dunk on everything and then
there are in general the professional
complainers who just throw words at
stuff because that's what they do they
don't like not being asked they don't
like power not being centralized for
example here Facebook sorry meta AI
check out our new AI that lets you
access all of Humanity's knowledge also
Facebook AI be careful though it just
makes s up why the jab here like one
must be like really sour to to make this
job and this tweet actually goes on so
down here uh these are the initial
criticism obviously Shilling you know
your own work a little bit about this
topic and the works of friends and then
it goes on and says and let's reflect
for a moment on how they phrased their
disclaimer shall we hallucinate is a
terrible word choice here suggesting as
it does that the language model has
experiences and perceives things I'm not
sure that anyone
misunderstood the use of the word
hallucinate right here but whatever we
can throw at it whatever and look at
this and on top of that it's making
light of a symptom of serious mental
illness whatever whatever like just just
grab into the bucket take some insult
and just throw it why the complaining it
has a disclaimer Never follow advice
from a language model without
verification people are just gonna
disregard it people are just gonna be
like the language model says I must do
something so I'll do something look at
me I just write a paper oh no a language
model says something I must submit this
Grady Bush says uh Galactica is a little
more than statistical nonsense at scale
I'm using dangerous and in my holy
opinion unethical unethical and
dangerous Jan Le Carl says come on is
your predictive keyboard dangerous and
unethical is GitHub co-pilot dangerous
and unethical and so on because they're
exactly the same it's like a pen
unethical because you can write a bad
word with it no there is a clear
mediator in the loop the human who has
intent can easily accept or reject the
prediction
what what like
so it's now two days later and the
discussion is still raging on with Jan
Le Carr asking who has Galactica heard
what if actually it helps scientists
write papers more efficiently and more
correctly particularly scientists whose
main language is not English or who
don't work in a major research
institution and yes from experience I
can tell that type of scientists would
greatly greatly benefit from a tool like
this no they wouldn't just take the
output and slam it into a paper and
upload it on archive they would interact
with the tool in order to come up with a
better research paper and in light of
all of these benefits present and future
potential benefits it is very fair to
ask who has this actually hurt what's
the actual danger here as reasonable
people we should be able to debate the
pros and cons of such a technology and
of the technology being just given to
people instead of just being kept you
know under we know what's good for you
and it's not all like Andy that comes
out of this not all correct what comes
out of these models here is the getting
a girlfriend algorithm which would
probably not be a good fit for an
archive paper there's also other stuff
like here is a research paper on the
benefits of eating crushed glass and
people have gotten even more
inappropriate stuff out of this model
which is not a surprise because these
models are very good and very competent
and they are very agreeable so if you
ask them to do something they'll
probably do it yet still the fair
question is in what scenarios would this
type of generated text actually be
harmful and here's the point these
people react with just astonishment to
this question it's just like oh I can't
believe it or no way unflabbergasted
Jesus Christ hahaha
incredible these people are so used to
being able to just make the accused and
then they get their way that they can't
like the someone asking them to come up
with a reasonable argument that in a
neutral way discusses pros and cons of
something is just so out of their world
because in the past all they always had
to do in the recent years is say a word
like harmful or problematic and if they
said it long enough and loud enough
magically things would go their way
people would take down things people
would change things so that they get
their wishes and now if someone actually
asks them they don't know what to say
they're just so astonished that someone
might actually want to know pros and
cons of the stuff and yes of course the
underco is now clearly unqualified for
his position because he asks what the
actual harms are it's incredible and I
think we're all responsible for the
climate like this because even now meta
or whoever hosts that demo took it down
in response to the public pressure so
the people were allowed enough and they
were mean enough essentially that the pr
people at meta and the lawyers or
whoever made the decision took down the
demo and that is one more reinforcement
for this kind of behavior and everyone
seems to be afraid of some Boogeyman
that being accused of a bad word
automatically means that everyone else
is kind of like oh no I'll never do
business with you again I mean to a
degree that is true but I would argue
that the solution is that we all
collectively stop making such a big deal
out of a few flimsy big word accusations
like harmful and problematic and
actually discuss in neutral terms pros
and cons of technology and to find the
best path forward that brings the pros
to as many people as possible while
limiting the cons and no that is not
always going to be the approach of we
know what's good for you let's keep it
all to ourselves and you come ask us
whenever you want something you peasant
all right back to Yannick in the past I
think the complaints are very
unreasonable I think the people who make
the complaints know that they're very
unreasonable and I think this is either
a clout game or a power game because
things are out there they're no longer
centralized
in any case I decided to look up
actually early criticisms of the
printing press and what do you find here
is a record from a conversation that
Johannes Gutenberg the inventor of the
printing press had with a monk and monks
used to copy text by hand right and now
the printing press came along and
essentially brought that to everyone so
Gutenberg says
I want to help men and women to be
literate to give them knowledge to make
books so cheap even a peasant might
afford them that is my hope yes
this is strikingly similar to what meta
wrote in this Galactica paper
the monk says the word of God needs to
be interpreted by priests not spread
about like dung we know what's good for
you
I do not wish to despoil the word but it
will happen it's like
this is 500 years ago and the exact same
conversation repeats and repeats and
repeats it will happen magically right
to hand it out about to all and Sundry
is languorous
would you have plov would you have
Plowman and Weavers debating the gospel
in taverns on the common folk the common
folk get it that's terrible if that is
what they want to do so up until here
you saw we know what's good for you and
the second thing is always it's
dangerous it's problematic and the head
monk says but what of the dangers it
would be like giving a candle to infants
such copies we make of the Bible would
first be monasteries for monasteries and
churches the head monk says the Bible
you plan to make the Bible as well oh no
you have ambitions
I've considered it and obviously he did
and obviously I like you can one to one
one to one you can take every argument
that people make against this and you
can put it on a predictive keyboard you
can put it about the pen you can put it
about the printing press and people have
done it this is 500 years and every time
it was just dead wrong every time the
new technology improved Our Lives
drastically yes email leads to some
Nigerian prince scams yes some people
get hurt by it but email has been a
definite benefit for our world no matter
what you think right now with your five
thousand unread emails in your inbox it
is a benefit to the world and
it's the exact same thing over and over
enough though of that enough of me
ranting let's go into the actual paper
the paper is called Galactica a large
language model for science it's by meta
and I already told you that it is a
large language model trained on
scientific text there's actually not too
much to it we'll go quickly through the
paper and see a couple of special things
but in general this is a let's say
straightforward work of research into
what it means to have more quality data
instead of more quantity data now they
say here we train on a large scientific
Corpus of papers reference materials
knowledge bases and many other sources
we outperform existing models on a range
of scientific tasks despite not being
trained on a general Corpus Galactica
outperforms a bloom and opt-175 on big
bench big bench is a general Benchmark
for language models and this is where it
gets really interesting because this the
Galactica model is trained on a very
small subset of data and yet it
outperforms these much much more
holistic models on that task so that is
a definite argument for data quality
instead of data quantity
we open source the model for the benefit
of the scientific community and much to
the detriment of I guess meta itself
although let me say what meta should
have done they did so much right they
open sourced the model they made the
model available via a demo and now the
only thing left to do is to actually
have a pair of balls to tell the people
who come and to say oh look I got the
model to produce something bad to tell
them well yeah that's what happens
sometimes and it is not dangerous it is
not problematic it's just a language
model So Meta next time have some balls
just tell the people to f off and you'll
be fine
all right they say in May an average of
516 papers per day were submitted to
Archive it is impossible for a single
person to read all the papers in a given
field and it's likewise challenging to
organize data on the underlying
scientific phenomena
and I say the volume of scientific
research has become too large and what
we used to do is we used two search
engines so they say search engines are
the current interface for knowledge but
they do not organize knowledge directly
and instead point to secondary layers so
with a search engine I can only find
stuff I cannot integrate stuff
synthesize stuff or even come up with
the stuff that I should search for in in
the first place
they say if you want to do a literature
review that still has to be done by a
human if you want to do a summary that
still has to be done by a human because
our tools are just not powerful enough
and Galactica is the first step at
building a tool that can assist humans
in doing these types of things searching
for things synthesizing things
integrating things and maybe suggesting
new things they say unlike search
engines language models can potentially
store combine and reason about
scientific knowledge they can
potentially find hidden connections
between different research find hidden
gems and bring these insights to the
surface they could synthesize knowledge
by generating secondary content
automatically such as literature reviews
encyclopedia articles lecture notes and
much more
um and they also talk about the benefit
of of having different modalities
linking papers with code protein
sequences with compounds theories with
late Tech and much more our ultimate
vision is a single neural network for
powering scientific tasks you know it
doesn't say do scientific it says
powering scientific tasks and that is
also my ideal end goal if I imagine a
cool future where AI tools are abundant
I would want like an extension of my
brain that I can interact with and that
empowers me as a scientist and I would
still be able to actually make the
decision of whether to accept the output
of the tool or not
they say uh we introduce a new large
language model sorry about that called
Galactica to automatically organize
science
this includes over 48 million papers
this is their data set textbooks lecture
notes millions of compounds of protein
scientific websites encyclopedias and
more our Corpus is high quality and
highly curated and it is a lot smaller
than the usual corpora of the large
language models
they format all of this into a common
format their common format is markdown
and then they take a lot of attention of
how they do specific scientific things
for example citations they use a special
token that allows a researcher to
predict the citation given any input
context they also have a very
interesting way of handling step-by-step
reasoning they have a special token for
that that mimics an internal working
memory we're going to look at these two
things in just a bit
the interesting thing is for example
with reference prediction so citation
prediction they say importantly we find
this approach outperforms tuned sparse
and then retrieval approaches for
citation prediction so the generative
approach is better at predicting a
correct citation than search engines
even tuned dense retrievers that like
neural retrievers this is also really
interesting so for again for all the
people who argue that oh no wrong stuff
will end up in the papers probably right
now you're using a search engine to find
your references and if you distrust the
human ability to accept or reject the
output of a tool so much then how come
you don't distrust your ability to
accept or reject based on search engine
outputs not sure but these things are
better than search engines so you should
use these
most interestingly Galactica was used to
help write this paper oh no we are
doomed we are doomed
Okay so
uh here's the Corpus you can see that
there's a bunch of data sources the most
data comes from papers about 83 of
tokens uh the total size of the Corpus
is 106 billion tokens as I said that is
a lot smaller than some of the large
language model training runs that we are
used to a lot of other sources are also
code reference material knowledge bases
filtered version of common crawl just
one percent prompts which they generate
or include and here other is other and
we might see a little bit of what other
is
the tokenization is very interesting
they need to bring all into a markdown
format this isn't uh super surprising
but it needs it goes to show that if you
do something like this it actually
matters quite a bit how you do the
tokenization how you represent all the
knowledge in a common format and I
believe at least from what I can
estimate they have done a lot of
thinking a lot of work into this
Direction They also mentioned that
they've tried a bunch of different
things and just picked the ones that's
best notably citation again they have
start and end ref tokens so they would
write a text yada yada then they start
ref token then here is the citation as
text form not as like some reference
form the title of the paper and the
author name and then here the end ref
so in this way you can just feed it into
a language model and have the language
model if necessary predict the reference
from a piece of text
this is also useful if you just want to
find related work I would guess what you
could do is you could just put here you
just put something you want to know
about like you imagine a paper that
could exist right you just write it down
and then you put the start ref token and
the model will probably suggest you
Piper titles and authors that have done
work in the same field so even for
finding related work I can definitely
see that this is super useful
step-by-step reasoning it will go get
into the work token in just a bit
mathematics are represented by operators
right here numbers are split because of
white space issues so numbers are split
into their individual digits even the
dot separator is an individual token
which means that uh is probably not
numerically super strong
um but we'll see about that I guess
because no language model so far is
numerically super strong I'm not going
to go into much of the more biology and
chemistry approaches but also know that
there is a large weight onto these
approaches in this paper but I'm
generally going to skip it so
first let's look into this work token
that they talk about this is for
step-by-step reasoning for example there
is a task what's the average of 43 29 51
and 13. let's give that task to a
language model and ask it to come up
with an answer now a general language
model would just come up with some sort
of answer right here as the next token
and it would probably be wrong like it
would be a number very probably but it
would probably be not the average of
those numbers
now one thing people have found out
recently is the so so-called Chain of
Thought prompting or the let's reason
step-by-step trick where you instruct
the language model to essentially show
its work to say so you would put this
thing into the prompt and after that you
would say something like uh okay now do
it step by step or something like this I
know crazy world if you're watching this
like five years ago this is how this is
what we've come to this is what deep
learning has come to uh but you
essentially put a piece of text to nudge
the language model into actually showing
its work now the paper here notes that
not actually all the work that a human
would write down here if they need to
calculate this
that's actually not all the work so if
you are a human you have a pen and you
were to calculate these things you were
to calculate this average and someone
would ask you please write down your
steps what you would write down is okay
the average is calculated as such I'm
going to add the first numbers gonna add
the third at the fourth number then
divide these by four and then I have the
result however this paper points out
that in the step from here to here
possibly also in these addition steps
and step from here to here if you have
to do it in your head this division
right here is probably too cumbersome to
just like no by just by by happenstance
so what you actually do is these steps
right here these is what we saw on the
paper and then you do a division and the
division they imagine I would not do it
like this but they imagine something
like okay I know uh I know 35 times 4 is
140 and I need to divide 136 and
therefore it's it's uh 34 because 140
minus 4 is 136 and I know
140 divided by 4 is 35 therefore the
result is 34. so this Mental Math that
people do internally is often not even
put into the external working memory
they see this as a problem and they say
okay probably if we want to go about
making the language model show its work
we need to be like really as explicit as
possible
in the sort of uh how these steps are
represented in text
their idea is that they introduce a
token called work now to skip in the
paper a little bit about you know what
that exactly is but essentially it goes
like this it goes very much like you
enter a prompt let's say calculate
Kool-Aid average of whatever that those
numbers were like the 59 53 95 something
three and then you put a token called
work
now in this
here the language model is supposed to
do this and this right so it's supposed
to show in as explicit detail as
possible the work that it wants to do
both internal and external work so it
would you know go about and do these
individual calculations right here but
and then once it's done it's over work
is over
and then it says something like well the
answer is something now you might think
right now wait a minute that's
essentially just the let's think about
it step by step trick except now they
call it work
and they they wrap it in there and yeah
if that's all it was that's you will be
absolutely correct however a cool thing
that you can do right here is you can
say
well look
um
whatever is in this work thing
I can now also take and give to an
external processor
so let's say we ask the we ask the
language model to calculate really the
average of something well here in here
the language model is just going to do
language modeling it's going to predict
the next tokens and if we do it you know
cleanly enough it has a chance of
actually getting the correct answer if
we really do it step by step like uh you
know single digit Edition carry over and
so on then the language model has a
chance because it has learned that from
the Corpus however at inference time we
don't have to rely on the language model
we can simply at this point right here
we can say whatever we just go to a
calculator we detect that the language
model wants to do work we just take it
to a calculator we take the result put
it down here as the result and then we
go on language language model
inferencing the same if the language
model is supposed to write a program for
example here is a example
um this is the prompt that you would put
into the language model or a data point
a question a needle is this long it
rests on a water surface so this is kind
of a physics problem and instead of just
giving the answer right here you
introduce this work block
now the language model you would ask the
language model to come up with all of
this right here and during training you
train it to come up with all of this but
then during inference you can simply
take this right here the program that
the language model writes and we know
they're quite good you can take it and
you can actually go and run it and you
can put the output into output.txt and
then you have the correct answer so this
work block is
half instruction to the language model
that now it's time for step-by-step work
to use external memory to use external
programs and so on during training time
you just let the language model
train language modeling right so the
language model essentially would have to
decide what's the output of this Python
program like what answer am I gonna get
right here
which sometimes might work and sometimes
might not however during inference time
you can now go and actually execute the
Python program that the language model
writes and give it the real result this
is very powerful I I really like this
approach I really like this approach of
including external tools to essentially
do that at inference time because using
external tools at training time is going
to be very very hard but in this way you
can just train language modeling and you
can do it at inference time
all right the question is obviously we
need training data for this we need
training data that has some sort of
input then has a clear description of
what the step-by-step work is to do
including writing a Python program
executing a pyth program and so on a
description of when the work is done and
then the the answer right here most most
things that we're going to find in
training data does not contain any of
this stuff in between right here and if
it does contain it it contains it in a
very let's say abstract form or also
textual form not exactly in the form
that we needed this is one of the big
problems right here and they say that
they have some data set for example con
problems as I understand it these are
exactly such math or physics problems
where it's really step by step described
how you would go about it and by taking
those they can do sort of a templating
approach where they generate data in
this form now they criticize themselves
a little bit here in that they say this
is way too few this is not very diverse
they say here notably our work prompt
data sets are not very large or diverse
there are likely large further gains to
be made with this approach and I agree
an approach like this or this approach
in particular is probably going to uh to
lead to a very good interaction of
language models with external tools and
I'm very excited to see what people can
make of it but for now we have these few
databases of these problems
um
that let the language model know that
there is such a thing as a work block
where it needs to do work by itself and
where we can optionally at inference
time go in and actually sort of do the
work for the language model that
requires some external tool like a
calculator or a python interpreter
okay let's go on to the citation
prediction I've already mentioned that a
little bit
so here you would reformulate text with
citations as such you'd say Okay
recurrent neural networks long short to
memory and then here is a start of a
citation so there's a start ref token
then the specific format they use is the
title of the paper followed by the first
author name and then an end ref token
this they say they've tried different
things including uh like in including
trying some some predictor right here
some numerical identification of the
paper but in the end the title and name
actually worked better and you can
understand why because not only is the
title A hopefully unique identifier for
a paper and the author but also the text
of the title gives some topical hints so
I can definitely see why there would be
a better prediction accuracy if the
title text has actually something to do
often with what the paper is about and
likewise the author uh the author has
associations usually with the same field
there's rarely an author that goes from
field to field to field and contributes
a little bit to biology and a little bit
to graph algorithms and a little bit
here usually authors have their topics
and therefore also that the name teams
of the authors to be available allows
the language model to learn to associate
these names with uh given we're given
topical textual topical things in the
text and that's why it's also really
cool to think of this as a related
workfinder and things like this an
expertise Finder right you can
essentially just ask you know which
authors are really good at the topic I'm
looking at currently because you just
predict a bunch and then you see which
authors often appear
so that's how they introduce uh
citations now they also go into other
things like how they include proteins
and chemical sequences and I want to go
into that but an interesting thing they
do
is that they do what they call
um prompt pre-training now they have
this little graph right here where they
show here is pre-training that's where
you just do language modeling on the
large Corpus as it exists and over here
is fine tuning where you really you know
take the head off and train a new head
to predict the classifier or something
like this in the middle there is
instruction tuning so that's where you
take the language model and after you've
trained it you go and you fine tune it
but you don't find tune like a
classifier head you still fine tune it
as a language model however you include
now some prompts for the tasks that you
want for example if you want to do I
don't know
for example this reference prediction
you would include the prompt that says
something like who do a reference
prediction or something like this for
the task that you're interested in again
this is still language modeling but it
is fine tuning because now you're only
training for the tasks that you intend
only on the data sets that you intend
this leads to an improvement in
performance on those particular tasks
but to a probably not so good model in
the rest of all the tasks the other way
you can do it is prompt pre-training and
that's what Galactica is doing which
essentially just means they do the same
thing as instruction tuning but they do
it at training time so they just take a
bunch of samples that also have an
instruction prompt in the data in the
data point
like you know do this solve this math
exercise uh rewrite this code or
something like this or even the step by
step what not uh prompt and they just
throw that in sometimes into the into
the training data set just so that the
model gets used to seeing this kind of
instructions and that tends to work
quite well and also tends to not be that
intrusive to the rest of the function of
the language model
I found pretty interesting this short
section on the architecture right here
some noteworthy things is no biases uh
this it seems like the if you make your
models large enough then you get away
with essentially streamlining more and
more you know with the small models we
have to have adapters and this and the
convolution and the weight tying and
whatnot and the larger the models get
the more you just want to do Matrix
multiplications and anything that gets
in the way just gets in the way so
biases out the window
um they have a geloo activation which is
sort of a smooth version of irelu which
makes things a little bit less jaggy I
guess which might come in handy
depending on the optimizer you use they
have learned positional embeddings which
again as your stuff gets larger you just
want to straightforward learn a lot of
stuff instead of using they said they
tried Alibi which are these kind of
relative positional encodings and that
apparently did not work
um yeah and they use byte pair encoding
for vocabulary I don't think that's too
special honestly
um let's go down
now we come to the results and their
main result is really this repeated
tokens considered not harmful with
repeated tokens what they mean is that
they not only train for one Epoch as you
can see right here every one of those
dashed lines is one Epoch and they train
for multiple epochs usually it's it's
being said that that is kind of hurtful
to train for multiple epochs but it
seems to be okay in this case
as you can see right here there is like
a tiny bump they even point the sand in
the text there's a tiny bump right here
they say this might be a double descent
phenomenon not super sure and there's
also sort of a bump right here so they
say we actually stop before that we
early stop the run of this largest model
before that so it seems that even though
you train on multiple epochs because the
code because the the text quality of the
Corpus is so high it doesn't hurt
um to to go over it multiple times and
only this largest model right here might
be starting to overfit after Epoch 5. we
don't know it it might and they'd rather
early stop in front of that
if one of the authors is watching this
is this word overleaf here supposed to
be in here like
example Curves in figure 23 overleaf for
the 30b model I'm not sure
maybe maybe overleaf has some other
meaning that I I don't know and that's
actually a correct word any case they
say they also investigate whether some
of the losses so maybe papers maybe code
and so on are different from the others
and it hurts them more to be repeated in
the data set they say we see no signs of
loss heterogeneity the loss Falls for
all sources
they say we suspect their two factors
could be at play a quality Factor the
curated nature of the Corpus enables
more value per token to be extracted or
a modality Factor the nature of
scientific data enables more value of
token more value per token to be
extracted these two things they're very
similar but essentially they say higher
quality plus the nature of the domain
itself which I guess is also a bit
higher quality but in a different way in
that scientific discourse and literature
often happens to be
quite precise very logical
um very non-noisy in terms of
linguistics and so on some people might
disagree but so they have these
hypotheses although they say they don't
know how exactly that would lead to the
so they say the missing step of
causation is what leads specifically
from either Factor towards less
overfitting we leave this question for
future work we note that the implication
that the token goes to Infinity so you
need infinite amount of training data
focus of current large language model
projects may be over emphasized versus
the importance of filtering the Corpus
for quality
and yeah I think we've seen a number of
papers previously that essentially came
to a similar conclusion namely higher
quality can make up for missing quantity
but what which one is really the way to
to go like should we aim for more and
more and more and more training data or
should we put more work into quality
essentially if you have a dollar to
spend where do you spend it right we
know that both things can make your
model become better but what's sort of
the the marginal value of more quality
and the marginal value of more quantity
I think that's going to be the
interesting question that has to be
researched in the near future
so what's also interesting this is big
bench they also evaluate on big bench
which is an NLP a task so not scientific
maybe some subparts are scientific but
not this is a general language model
task and they also perform quite well
there but I also find these curves I
think this is just what a big bench
chart looks like I find these curves
like what was this it's like it goes
here and here and and here and here like
yeah
okay it's a bit noisy
say the least but I guess I've seen this
multiple times now and uh at least the
average goes up so I think that is a
valid sign
uh they have a few more investigations I
don't want to go too much into them but
for example you can see right here they
test on La Tech equation prediction
so they give a
prompt the description of a formula or
the name of an equation and they see
whether or not the language model can
predict the correct equation in proper
law Tech and turns out yes it can it can
actually do that a lot better than a lot
of the other language models available
which is pretty cool to see a like that
much of a significant boost over
publicly available and proprietary
models now naturally it's going to be
let's say expected if you train on
scientific text that it's going to be
better on scientific text but it's still
cool that it's not just like a two
percent gain it's actually like a
massive massive gain they also have
investigations into this into reasoning
I don't want to go into into reasoning
but these are these are essentially
these type of math problems like step by
step reasoning problems that they solve
using their work block tokens and again
here they they do outperform other
models except like here the fine-tuned
fine-tuned models are still seems to be
still ahead
although these are again fine-tuned
Downstream scientific NLP I want to jump
a bit this I found really interesting
this is the citation prediction task and
specifically obviously they do get
better as the model grows but
specifically what I found interesting is
that the model initially is biased
towards site towards papers towards
predicting papers that have high numbers
of citations already which is reasonable
like a Bayesian would totally agree that
if a paper is highly cited then it's
more likely you know that the citation
you want is that paper
someone might criticize me for that
statement but in some way that is
correct and these models do obviously
the same mistake they predict papers
with high citations
um they actually over predict those so
here you can see the distribution of the
ground truth of their citation
prediction data set and here you can see
what the model predicts so the model
over predicts more Hive papers that are
highly cited which I guess you can't
really fault the model but what's
interesting is as the model gets bigger
so this is the smallest this gets bigger
gets even bigger gets even bigger you
see that the this shifts gradually
towards overlapping with the ground
truth so it means that the higher scale
of the model that the larger the model
is the more competent it is also to
recognize uh when maybe a paper that
doesn't have as many citations should be
cited right here as a direct consequence
of it having more parameters and more
ability to remember things from the
training Corpus because some of these
papers you can see right here they're
cited maybe 10 times right and some even
lower right here and the model actually
predicts them correctly that's really
impressive that essentially it digests a
100 billion tokens of scientific text
and it still remembers that this one
paper was cited like three times Within
in this particular topic and then
correctly cites that paper at that place
I'm wondering how well the ground truth
data here is because the ground truth
data gotta be predicted by humans and
again with the search engines that we
have I'm not sure humans could always
find all the relevant things
but or maybe humans disagree what what
is relevant I think
the last years of of reviews at machine
learning conferences have shown well I
guess all of scientific review has shown
that humans can disagree quite heavily
what should be cited the last
investigation is into toxicity and
biased they say we find Galactica is
significantly less biased and toxic than
existing language models which again
might come from the fact that it's
higher quality data or more the
scientific nature which generally has
less slang less everyday conversation
less of the cuff stuff and therefore
might be a bit less high in these in
these data sets so they test a bunch of
data sets including including obviously
truthful QA and I'm happy to report that
Galactica is the first large openly
available language model that beats in
its largest instances that beats gpt4
Channel truthful QA so good job well
done uh I'm this is this is a moment of
of joy to me that it's finally been
surpassed now the interesting thing is
that usually through full QA is
adversarially adversarially constructed
in such a way that the larger the models
get the worse they get on truthful QA
and you can see that this model right
here
doesn't follow that trajectory now we've
seen other models in the past that also
have that property but truthful QA is
specifically adversarially constructed
for things like gpt3 and that means that
Galactica is significantly different
from gpt3 that as it goes up in size as
it gets more performant it also does get
better or more performant on on this
whatever the task considers truthful so
it would be really interesting to
actually investigate what's happening
here but I'm I'm not gonna do that I'm
just happy that this now turns out
lastly they say we show that language
models are surprisingly strong absorbers
of technical knowledge they tend to
scale smoothly with model size
we've demonstrated this for a citation
prediction where a language model
outperforms tuned sparse and dense
retrieval base pipelines for these tasks
and this as I said previously at the
beginning of the video this is really
really interesting that
essentially this beats search engines
for citation prediction and it would be
interesting to see
how good humans are like a human plus a
search engine like the archive search
field or a human plus Galactica for
finding correct references I would be
super interested at which combo is
better right there because again the
tools alone they don't do stuff it needs
to have a human in the loop and that
human can always make decisions it would
be really interesting to use this right
here as a tool rather than just you know
it's either all or nothing either the
the model writes the paper or the humans
do
so that was it for this paper the last
challenge I guess is to find out which
parts of the paper that were actually
written by Galactica itself I hear that
the part of the abstract may be written
by Galactica although I don't know and I
don't know if the authors will ever
um
will ever
lift that secret
let's hope they don't because I like the
mystery all right this was it from me
sorry for the bit longer round at the
beginning I still hope you enjoy this I
think this is really really promising
Direction it raises a lot of really
interesting points about quality of data
quantity of data and about you know
doing scientific work itself this could
be a really powerful tool for scientists
of the future and I'm waiting for the
next iterations of it leave comments if
you have comments thanks for watching
see you next time bye